Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan. Man hört vielleicht ein bisschen das Geraunen im Hintergrund.
Gerade stehen noch viele an für Getränke. Es ist heiß in Frankfurt.
Aber hier drin ist es ein bisschen klimatisiert. Wir freuen uns jetzt gleich.
Ein bisschen klimatisiert. Hier sind gerade 800 Wärmepumpen reingelaufen.
Ja, aber die Anlage gibt ihr Bestes.
Wir freuen uns also jetzt gleich darauf, über etwas zu sprechen,
was uns am Herzen liegt. Nämlich einmal das Lesen, was wir immer in diesem Salon
tun, zum anderen das in die Oper gehen.
Darüber hinaus wollen wir aber auch etwas ergründen, wie funktioniert eigentlich
eine Gesellschaft, die die ganze Zeit smartphonebasiert operiert und dann trotzdem
noch hin und wieder zu einem Buch greifen sollte.
Genau, ganz metaphorisch, metaphysisch, wie auch immer gesprochen.
Ich wurde eben schon gefragt, ist heute AI dran?
Ich habe gesagt, interessante Frage, aber nicht so wie du glaubst.
Aber es ist auch ein bisschen Künstlichkeit der Intelligenz dran,
oder? Ja, nicht ChatGPT, sondern anderes heute.
Vom Papst bis hin zu YouTube-Tagebüchern.
Also ganz interessant, junge Männer führen jetzt Tagebücher via YouTube.
Also nochmal so ganz klassisches YouTube eigentlich, wie es einmal begann.
Und wir haben drei Gäste.
Wir verraten noch nicht, wer es sein wird, aber wir haben drei Gäste,
um die Themen noch mal punktuell zu vertiefen.
Wir sollten aber noch ankündigen, was wir als nächstes lesen.
Und das hat ja auch schon fast eine Tradition bei uns im Podcast, im Salon.
Wir lesen nämlich das neue Buch von Julia Friedrich.
Julia Friedrich hat ein Buch geschrieben, nun über die Reichen in Deutschland. Crazy Rich Reiche.
Und du verfolgst sie ja schon noch länger. Wir haben ja Working Class gelesen, damals im Salon.
Generation Erben hattest du aber, glaube ich, auch damals schon auf dem Schirm.
Generation Erben kam, glaube ich, bevor wir im Podcast so gesprochen haben.
Deswegen lief das immer so mit.
Ihr Ursprungswerk Gestatten Elite. Damit hat sie ja für Aufregung gesorgt,
als sie da mal gezeigt hat, wie die Beraterwelt so tickt.
Wir wissen heute, die Beraterwelt hat sich deswegen nicht verändert.
Wir lesen also heute dann ein Buch über die Superreichen und erfahren mehr über
sie, ohne dass sich wahrscheinlich viel ändert.
Aber wir können ja mal darauf abklopfen, nicht nur wie viel Realitätssinn und
Gehalt, sondern auch wie viel Traktion als politisches Buch da so drinstecken könnte.
Wir haben ja verschiedene Strategien wie Kristallisieren oder was auch immer besprochen.
Also wir werden das Buch sehr wohlwollend lesen, das sowieso,
und dann mal so auf Praxis abklopfen.
Das war ja bei Blüthorn uns nicht vergönnt.
Sagst du. Du wirst jedenfalls nicht einfordern können von Julia Fudels,
sie soll bitte mal Empirie liefern. Das wird sie tun.
Das ist ja etwas, was sie auch wahnsinnig gut kann, mit der Reportage reingehen.
Also tatsächlich mit den Leuten
dort sprechen und sich dann ihre Gedanken noch einmal darüber machen.
Wir sind sehr gespannt, denn wir hatten ja schon im Podcast über ihre superreichen Doku gesprochen.
Und schauen, was jetzt dieses Buch dann zu bieten hat. Also Crazy Rich wird
dann die nächste Lektüre.
Sehr gut. Und jetzt holen sich immer noch viele Leute Getränke,
aber wir werden doch demnächst anfangen.
Genau. Und wer jetzt auch gleich den Live-Sommer-Salon hören will,
der braucht einfach nur ein Abo abzuschließen.
Das ist am einfachsten möglich über Steady. Und das kostet drei Euro.
Ab drei Euro im Monat kann man das abschließen. Es geht aber auch über Patreon,
wenn man dort schon angemeldet ist.
Oder Apple ist auch möglich.
Genau, es gibt die einfachen Wege, über die man stolpern kann oder man nimmt
einfach Steady, das von uns präferierte und auch am günstigste Angebot.
Und dann sehen wir uns alle im Salon. Prima, bis gleich.
Guten Abend.
Vielen Dank.
So. Wir haben gehört, es saßen noch nicht alle, sondern es wollten noch Leute
Getränke. Wir können den Rest platzieren oder es geht doch dann ganz schnell.
Es geht ganz schnell, denke ich. Die Frage wird natürlich sein,
guten Abend meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, liebe Freunde des Podcasts.
Die Frage wird sein, was wird hier eigentlich vorwiegend getrunken?